nach 70 jahren ehe hat der rentner
julius es seine frau mit einer decke
erstickt er tat es angeblich aus liebe
um seine frau zu erlösen
denn sie litt an alzheimer demenz hatte
schmerzen und litt auch angeblich an
wahnvorstellungen
seit gestern wird der fall vor gericht
verhandelt vor dem würzburger
landgericht der rentner hatte auch
versucht sich selbst das leben zu nehmen
und den prozess verfolgt für uns jörg
völkerling geht es ja auch schon ein
urteil gefallen wie das seien
ausgefallen heute zwei jahre haft auf
bewährung wegen totschlags in einem
minderschweren fall dazu
10.000 euro geldauflage an die caritas
main spessart und das ganze in einer
dreijährigen bewährungszeit in der sich
julius es nichts zu schulden kommen
lassen darf jeden wohnsitzwechsel
mitteilen muss der haftbefehl wurde von
richter hans büttner danach aufgehoben
der richter hatte dass das war seine
letzte entscheidung seines langen
berufslebens und er sagte aber
ausdrücklich diese milde bestrafung sei
kein freibrief für nachahmungstäter nur
der absolute ausnahme charakter dieser
tat habe zu diesem milden urteil führen
können und der fall hat ja auch in der
öffentlichkeit für hohe wellen
geschlagen wie her geht an die
öffentlichkeit jetzt auf dieses urteil
ja sehr kontrovers der richter hat
versucht das einfach auch noch mal zu
erklären und hat ist vollkommen auch dem
rentner gefolgt in seiner argumentation
er den bemerkenswerten satz gesagt es
habe keinen einzigen punkt zu lasten des
rentners gegeben er habe sich in einer
depressiven verstimmung gefunden habe
das unrecht der tat einsehen können aber
nicht danach handeln können letztlich
die größte strafe sei für ihn
wahrscheinlich dass ersetzen das leere
haus zurückkehrt und dort immer seine
tote frau sehen
der bayerische innenminister hatte ich
mehrere justizminister georg eisenreich
hat sich uns gegenüber geäußert hat
anerkannt dass es natürlich ein recht
auf selbstbestimmtes sterben gebe aber
der sterbewillige müsse jederzeit dieses
tun aktiv selbst bestimmen können auch
jemand der aktiv das ganze tut selbst
wenn er dabei denkt er haben wir im nach
besten bilden und im sinne des
betroffenen mache sich strafbar
strafrecht halte allerdings bestimmungen
für härtefälle
um so eine härte abzumildern
andererseits gibt es auch schon heute
den ersten leser der sich mit bild
gemeldet hat gesagt hat angeboten hat er
würde diese 10.000 euro geldstrafe
übernehmen weil ihnen dieser ganze fall
so zu herzen berührt hat mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren